express the area of a rectangle with
length for X Y and with 2y as a monomial
monomial just means just one term
monomial so let's think about a
rectangle so let me draw a rectangle
here let me draw a rectangle and they're
telling us that the length is 4 X Y the
length is 4 X Y and they're telling us
that the width is 2 y the width is 2i
and just as a bit of refresher we know
the area of a rectangle is just the
width times the length or the length or
the height times the width or however
you want to view it just the product of
its two dimensions so the area of this
rectangle the area is going to be equal
to this length for XY is going to be
equal to 4 X Y 4 XY times the width
times the width times 2y times 2y and we
can simplify this we have a 4 times a 2
we have a 4 times - whenever you're just
taking a product of a bunch of things
you can switch the order however you
like as long as it's all multiplication
so 4 times 2 that gives us 8 then we
have this X sitting here that is the
only X we have there so it's 8 times X
and then we have a Y here we can view
that as Y to the first and then we have
another Y there we could view that as Y
to the first so Y times y you could view
that as Y squared or you could say look
Y the first times y to the first same
base add the two exponents 1 plus 1 is 2
so it's 8 X Y squared this cook this Y
squared covers both that Y and that Y
over there and we're done we've
expressed the area of this rectangle as
a monomial